[Musique]
on le surnomme le château des senteurs
on respire d'abord la fragrance de son
grand cèdre multi centenaires puisant
penche le nez au dessus des ses
parterres fleuris élan pousse enfin la
porte
alors ici nous sommes dans l'actuelle
entrée où nous avons décidé de mettre la
santé des magnolias à l'intérieur de
cette bâtisse du xvème siècle chaque
pièce s'est ainsi vu attribuer une
couleur olfactives un parfum
judicieusement associé au lieu ici la
salle à manger salle à manger où nous
avons choisi donc lassante delambre
lambres pourquoi tout simplement puisque
sur ses murs comme vous pouvez le
constater il y a quelque chose
d'exceptionnel puisqu'il n'en existe que
huit en france ce sont les cuire des
flandres à la différence des cuir de
cordoue les flandres y ont ajouté les
coloris exceptionnels qui sont les
oranje le bleu l'or lepoutre le vert
tout ça pour donner une vie à ce château
puisque quand vous rentrez dans une
maison vous avez des bonnes senteurs ça
vous plaît ça vous avez envie d'y
revenir
et voilà on voulait donner une vie au
château d'enghien fort par le biais de
ses senteurs